um
okay
you should be all said representative
weiler
good morning we'll call this session to
order
this is the budget briefing from your
house finance committee
on the budget that we have recently
passed in the committee
we appreciate when we got to the trailer
bill
all the help from all the policy
committees that we submitted parts to
addressing hb1 the budget committee
amendment
is a balanced budget does not rely on
new taxes
of federal stimulus funds from the
american rescue plan
act of 2021. we'll be showing some of
the
uh slides on the on the screen as we go
committee amendment pro provides 13
billion 460 million in total funds this
includes
5 billion 420 million in general and
education trust funds which is
1.4 percent below previous biennium
the revenues for this budget the
committee amendment utilizes revenue
projections from existing sources which
were estimated
unanimously by the house ways and means
committee in march
committee amendment utilizes
and it includes various tax reductions
including
decreasing the statewide education
property tax by 100 million
reduces the meals and rooms tax rate to
8.5 percent
reduces the business enterprise tax rate
to
0.55 percent and increases the filing
threshold
and reduces the business profits tax
rate to
seven point six percent and fully phases
out
the interest and dividends tax over five
years
the rainy day fund we are able to
increase the rainy day fund
to 142 6 million at the end of the
biennium
which will be the highest total in the
state's history
so we're going to the pie charts my
favorite for
trying to get aggress a grasp on
what's happening so this this first
pie chart is the general funds
and the categories that they are spent
in this is just the 3 billion
463.1
that is later explained in the overall
picture of the 13 billion dollar budget
remember this is for two years
so as you can see the majority of the
general funds
52.5 goes to the category health and
social services
another big piece goes to category 6
education
346 million or 10 percent of the general
funds
general government is 15.6 percent
that's category one category two the
administration of justice and public
protection
is 19.6
and category three resource protection
and development
is 2.2 and transportation gets a small
amount
0.1 percent to help with the lack of
highway funds normally it's the highway
funds that
that fund transportation moving on to
this is the whole the whole thing 13
billion dollars
the entire budget and this is showing
you
the appropriations by category
and of course again the largest category
is health and social services
and that's 43.2 percent of the budget
five billion eight hundred ninety nine
point nine million
the next largest one is category six
education
that's that accounts to 22 of the budget
it takes in some federal funds as well
as the general funds which we just
looked at
category one general government 7.7
category 2 administration of justice and
public
protection 11.8
and then category 3 resource protection
and development
is 5.4 that's uh
department of environmental services
fish and game and so on
category 4 transportation is 9.9
of this overall budget when we start
taking into account
turnpike highway funds and so on
so that's that's the way the total funds
get spent
now here are the source if we move to
these are appropriations by
source so these are where the
the federal where the monies came from
to fund the above budget of the 13
billion
665 million and as you see
federal funds are a very big piece
normally they run around 30 percent this
year they went up to 31.5
some of this was the cares act recovery
funds that are coming in
we don't have all the american recovery
act
um funds yet and we so we can't put them
in the budget we don't know the strings
on them and don't know
all that details but this is because
something you may have heard of fnap
federal medicaid uh
assistance percentage it went up a
little bit on several categories due to
the cares act
bringing it to 31.5
then education trust fund again is a big
piece
15 and a half percent add that to the
general
fund of 25.3 they're also
a major part of this budget other funds
there's too many to mention but this
includes the
tuition in the community colleges it's
fines and fees in some cases it's a lot
of
200 separate different little things
including interest on
on the monies the treasurer holds and so
on
uh liquor fund that's that's the
profit from selling liquor in our state
liquor stores 1.1
of the budget highway fund is three
point six percent
and fish and game fund is point two
percent
turnpike is two and a half percent
and that comes in separately as does
sweepstakes fund for
a point two percent so those are the
sources that help make up this thirteen
the operating budget
of unrestricted revenue again we're back
to the general funds
to show you where we collected them and
what our major
sources of funds are business profits
tax being the biggest one
at twenty seven point eight percent
next would in the business enterprise
tax we usually group those together when
we're doing total revenue
that's only two point seven percent
about ten percent of the business
profits tax
liquor sales eight point one percent
court fines and fees point seven percent
securities revenue those are the
registration fees for
um mutual funds that want to be sold in
our state have to pay a registration fee
that brings in two and a half percent of
the revenue about 84 million
insurance tax brings in 262 million
seven point seven percent there's a tax
on every insurance policy sold
communications tax that's on your phone
bill there's a couple places
that brings in seventy seven point six
million 2.3 percent
the beer tax it's pretty obvious where
that comes from
26 million medicaid recoveries
that's a complicated uh
formula run through hhs and we get about
6.2 million back from that real estate
transfer tax
at seven percent you'll hear about that
on your county budgets
tobacco tax brings in eight percent that
had a pretty big year this last year
and then meals and rooms tax another
major one 20
of the revenue that comes in so
i like these pie charts because they
give you a pretty good idea of
how all the different pieces fit
together and
where they all come from and where they
all go out so now i'm going to ask the
division
chairs to brief on the details
of the adjustments they made in the
sections of the budgets
that were in their part of the budget
we'll start first with
chairman lynn ober of division one
thank you mr chairman as you can see
from the division one that's up there
we have made a number of changes the
first bullet point
talks about 1.7 million dollars
of errors that were in the das budget
they were double budgeted for 600 plus
thousand dollars of maintenance to
buildings
if you look at the third bullet point
cyber security
was budgeted in error in their budget
which was another 600 plus
thousand dollars and if you look at the
fourth bullet point
there was 517 thousand dollars that was
double budgeted
prematurely for the law enforcement
commission
once we corrected all of those we were
able to restore the 20 positions that
had been laid off
because of the double budgeting the last
bullet point talks about the lakeshore
redevelopment planning commission that
has been
working for a long time on the lakeshore
region facility which the state wishes
to
sell and which would save over five
hundred thousand dollars a year
in doit we restored four positions
that would provide support typically
he's in dra we funded two working on
another positions
that will collect an additional three
million in state revenue
but there's a stream going on fully fund
flood control programs which is 1.8
billion
this goes to our towns and cities
state treasury distributes 152.6 million
of meals and rooms revenues to our towns
and cities
this was an increase of 15 million over
the prior biennium
for this statutory district distribution
we reallocated six million dollars of
general fund
to the department of corrections why
the governor had unfunded in his budget
because of the pandemic where we were
expecting really low revenues
all of the vocational training and the
academic training
in addition we had the treasury talk to
doe
about using vlax our virtual
learning academy for people who need to
complete their high school diploma
because of improvements in our prison
system
and the new women's prison we will now
be able to use them
we approve the governor's requested
change to statutory cap
on the rainy day fund the office of
strategic initiatives
and the puc have now become
the department of energy however
the planning piece was moved to the
department
of business and economic affairs where
it should have belonged
anyway
we transferred the appropriation for
business transport from the department
of
administrative services to the judicial
branch
and the reason we did that it is the
judicial branch that determines
when prisoners are transferred and how
much security they need
in each courthouse at the same time the
state law
says that the money budgeted will be
spent
and if it more money is needed then they
prorate the amount given to the
counties we did not want to cut the
county budgets this will allow the
branch
that does the spending to allocate and
watch the budget we also provided
the supreme court the authority to
transfer funds within the judicial
branch's budget
as deemed necessary this has worked well
in the past such transfers in excess of
a hundred thousand dollars
will require approval of the fiscal
committee just as they do for all
agencies
we fully funded the department of
military affairs and veteran services
including new staff
we also provided that they will start to
coordinate mental
health programs and will collaborate
with the va
there are some new programs being
proposed by the va
that would benefit veterans in our
states
the department of agriculture and
markets and food was also fully funded
and in addition the house passed a bill
creating a database for animal records
for transferring money from certain
funds
this budget makes the required
appropriation for the maintenance of
this database
in the department of justice we
recognize general fund savings of 278
thousand dollars by delaying the start
of a new program
and two new attorney positions
in many cases the department of justice
is not able to hire
all new attorney positions at the
beginning of the fiscal year i.e july
1st
this allows some time to create all of
those job descriptions
get the paperwork done and bring them on
at the beginning
of january however it does give us the
savings
the banking department also fully funded
ask that we
change the charge for the public deposit
investment pool because there was a
conflict
for the department's role in regulating
state chartered entities
and the commissioner's role in
supporting the public deposit
investment pool we did support that
in the liquor commission we amended the
state liquor laws i have to thank
representative peter leishman who did a
lot of work in this area
we're going to change the enforcement
division from a quote unquote police
division
to a licensing and education division
which is what we intended them to be
the uniform positions will end on
december 31st 2021
and that provides six months for the
officers to join other police entities
while fully funding all the positions
that have to be paid for paying
accumulated leave
and other termination costs as mentioned
the department of energy was formed
using osi and the puc
this proposes an energy department which
combines not only the puc and osi but
also the consumer advocate
and has long been supported by the
consumer advocate is the best way to go
for the consumers in our state site
evaluation committee work will be done
by this agency
and the house finance amendment makes
technical corrections
to the proposed language and moves some
position to the appropriate functional
area
it also eliminates some positions
in the department of corrections we
restored the transitional housing
programs at shea farm and calumet house
in manchester traditional housing costs
significantly less to operate than
keeping a person
in a prison bed without this resource
there is no way for our prisoners to
transition back to normal living
make sure that they get a job take care
of themselves
this will reduce recidivism it restores
the transitional housing program
coordinator position and the operating
costs for the housing program at shea
farm
it also restores the transitional
housing programmer coordinator
position and the operating costs for the
housing program
in manchester it transferred the staff
back from the men's prison
in concord to the transitional housing
restores funding to the department's
educational vocational programs
these long-standing educational programs
at the state prisons have reduced
recidivism and contributed to a person's
success upon release from prison the
goal is
to help people become successful
citizens
and not to return to prison where it's
very expensive to house them
it also provides the department subject
to the approval of the fiscal committee
and the governor and the executive
council
the ability to transfer funds between
and among appropriations
for salaries overtime pay holiday pay
part-time pay and benefits this language
is
language is critical because we
frequently have a high
staff vacant position count there
in the department department of
employment security
assistant commissioner labors asked us
to add the labor's integrity data hub
for the purpose of preventing and
detecting fraud in the unemployment
compensation
and we did that judicial council budget
was
fully funded as presented and it
provides the language that in the event
that expenditures for termination of
parental rights
are greater than what we expected they
also
support indigent parents it's hard to
know
two years in advance exactly how much
funding they will need so they can come
to fiscal committee to get more funding
in the department of business and
economic affairs we
increase the funding to the small
business development center
they will now have 225 000 in each of
the two years
the last year for which they we they
spent money
they spent 160 000 so we funded them
at more than they last spent
we did this by reducing for 400 000
from the money which was 17 million that
was budget for
for travel and tourism in the
department of environmental services
we reluctantly suspended the state aid
grants for the biennium
however we think
that the economy is going to be stronger
than the revenue plan
that was presented to the house by the
house ways and meats
so we added a section in house bill 2
that will allow the des commissioner to
come to the fiscal committee every six
months
and request unrestrict unrestricted
revenue
above the revenue plan and pay for these
grants
it was our intention to show that the
legislature supports these grants and
supports payment of these grants
thank you representative ober and
division two
chair representative umberger will brief
i'll start with the department of
transportation
and this is uh based on the
revenue estimates we fully fund
highway block grants this is money that
goes to cities and towns
and this was budgeted at 68.1 million
over the biennium and in recognition
of the pandemic's impact on the road
toll
and vehicle fee revenue the budget
provides an additional
four million dollars in general fund
appropriation
to this program based on revenue
estimates
again we were able to fully
fund the highway and bridge betterment
program
at 80 million 80.6
million dollars over the biennium this
program is funded
by uh three cents per gallon on
road toll fees and a portion
of the sb 367
of .042 cents restricted toll
and is primarily primarily used for
paving
on state highway systems as well as
bridge rehabilitation and other work
to improve the conditions of the road
system
across the state in recognition
of the pandemic's impact
on road to revenues the budget also
provides an additional 5 million
in general funds appropriation to this
program
we also provide
approximately 11.8 million over the
biennium
for maintenance and acquisition of fleet
vehicles and equipment this includes
6 million from the general fund
approximately 66.6 million over the
biennium
was allocated to fund winter maintenance
operations and this includes an
additional 4
million from the general funds
we also provide 13.6 million
over the biennium for the state aid
bridge program
which provides the state match for
construction
or reconstruction of municipally owned
again the pandemic had an impact on
enrollments
but it allows the doe to make certain
adjustments
to the free and reduced meal eligible
pupil counts
for the purpose of calculating adequate
education grants
this would provide approximately 6.
16.7 million in fy 22
and 17.5 million in 2023
of additional school aid to the
districts above the estimates
in the current law relative to the
fy 23 proposed 100 million dollar
reduction
in the statewide property tax or swept
the necessary requirements for to make
the supplemental
education payments in the event of
municipalities
education grant is negatively affected
this ensures that state aid would in no
way
be impacted by the swept production
in recognition of a one-year lag between
student accounts and adequacy payments
it provides full funding to school
districts
that began full-day kindergarten
programs
in 2019 and and
2020. language included in hb2
would ensure school districts that began
full-day kindergarten programs
would receive full adequacy payments in
the first year of the program
we also fully fund aid to the public
charter schools
based on enrollment estimates provided
by doe
totaling approximately 47 million in
and 49 million in 2023.
also over the biennium we provide
a million dollars for lease aid to
public charter schools
and also increase the maximum annual
aid amount per school from 30 000
to 50 000 we provide 79.9 million for
school building aid
which includes 52 million
for payments on previously projected
projects
19 million for new school building aid
and 8 million to make accelerated
payments
on previously approved projects designed
to pay down
existing state obligations sooner
and this of course would allow new
building aid projects
in future budgets we also provide
67.2 million over the biennium to fully
fund the special education for higher
cost
students to aid school districts
this is 5.6 million over what the
governor put
in his budget we provide 18 million over
the biennium for career and technical
education
tuition and transportation aid to school
districts
and we provide 1.5 million
over the biennium for the new hampshire
robotics
education development program
in the lottery hb2
authorizes historical horse racing
which is consistent with hb 626
as recommended by house ways and means
which is estimated to generate
18 million dollars in additional
education
trust fund revenue over the biennium
for the community college and the
university system
of new hampshire we maintain separate
governance
and state support appropriations for the
community college and the university
system while exploring a new commission
to study and assess the potential for
establishing
a collaborative and strategic merging
of the two systems also we appropriated
1.5 million to the commission to carry
out
its work we provided funding
for the community college 56 million per
year
and the university system at 88.5
million per year which is the same as
the 2021 levels
we also move the administration of the
dual and concurrent role
enrollment program better known as
running start
from the department of education to the
community college
and provide 1.5 million per year
for the program in the department of
safety
we provide highway funds
to excuse me
provide the department of highway funds
which
is associated with collecting motor
vehicle fees and road tolls
at a level below the statutory limit
which is 26 percent of the highway fund
we established the body warn and
dashboard camera fund
with the one million dollars to provide
matching grants to local law enforcement
agencies
to assist with the purchase maintenance
and replacement
equipment as well as ongoing costs
associated with data storage
this is in response to a recommendation
of the new hampshire commission on law
enforcement accountability
community and transparency or probably
better known
by its acronym leak
we also provided additional funding for
the
department's top three prioritized needs
two positions in the toxology lab and
one position
in the forensic lab these positions will
help to
meet demand and prevent delays and
backlogs
in fish and game by the way which is
healthier than it's been
in years we provided approximately 1.2
million
in general funds over the biennium
and this money a hundred thousand per
year
it excuse me is for non-game species
and five hundred thousand per year for
uh to help with the enforcement
and the fish and game fund is projected
to have a surplus
of over 6 million dollars at the end of
i'm not exactly sure how far back you'd
have to go
to find fish and game with a surplus
the police standards and training
council
we supported the governor's recommended
funding levels
including 210 000 over the biennium for
purposes of providing
crisis intervention team training
program
and again this was a recommendation out
of
the leak committee and finally
we made no changes to the new hampshire
excellence and higher education
endowment trust fund
however it does authorize the new
hampshire college tuition
savings plan advisory council
unique funding to transfer funds between
it
and the governor's scholarship program
which as it deems appropriate and also
we are forming a commission to develop
recommendations
to us like to establish a single neutral
and independent statewide entity
to receive complaints alleging
misconduct
regarding all sworn and elected law
enforcement officers
again this is in response to the leak
commission
and it also sets aside a hundred
thousand dollars
to fund the proposed entity in 2023.
uh thank you mr chairman uh division
three
let's start stop there and note that
division three
starts with a table and the reason we
start with the table
is because this table tells a huge
part of our overall story of what we've
done
in division three this term uh if you
if you look to the left you'll see in
the 2018 and 19 budget
where we ended at about 723 million
dollars
and then in the current budget that
we're in
there was a massive unsustainable
unrealistic growth rate of 17.4 percent
so one of the first strategic decisions
that we took was how do we get this
unsustainable growth under control
and when you take a look at what we did
in fy 22
and 23 it's still growing
at 3.7 percent but we did bend the cost
curve down
considerably dramatically but for some
of you who aren't happy with a 3.7
percent increase
let me just put that into perspective
we've had a large number
of new clients enter into
the health and social services arena of
our
state due to the pandemic and so if you
take a look at uh
client increases throughout the system
you'll see that there's more demand for
services
so so the three percent 3.7 percent i
think is
a responsible provision of direct
health care services to the residents of
new hampshire
so overall the compound growth rate went
up 4.9
per year so if you go back to the
previous budget
go through the current budget and go to
the end of the proposed budget
the growth rate overall on a compounded
basis is 4.9 percent
i think that's still unsustainable but
it's a good start in just one budget
so on the next page
[Music]
if we could scroll down to yeah there we
go thank you
um the first paragraph provides a lot of
those
same percentages we just went over using
words so i won't
re-state all that to you the second
bullet
down where it talks about incorporating
a back of the budget reduction of 30
million
even after that 30 million we still
funded a growth rate of 3.7 percent
so what we've done though is we've
set some very clear priorities on what
parts of the department ought to come
first
and we listed them and you can read them
there yourselves
they are direct service provision
so we exempt developmental services
including the acquired brain disorder
services and children's
income support services the children's
health insurance program
and county programs to include the state
share of funding for nursing homes
so so we've set some real priorities on
on where this money and personnel ought
to go
and for those who are concerned that
we haven't given adequate guidance to
the department i would just want to
point out
that if you go through the briefing
books that we've been provided
there's probably a hundred federal and
state
laws that they have to comply with
dhhs is not suffering from a lack of
guidance
and and that's before you start to get
to the regulations
so so what this back of the budget cut
does is it says to the leadership
in the department of health and human
services we trust you
we think you're competent we think
you're leaders
we want you to go through and
reprioritize using the growth
and resources that we've given you so
that we
do the most care for the most number of
our
residents you get to the next line
the next line down starts to talk about
a second back of the budget cut
this is a a reduction
on paper it's a paper reduction
otherwise known as a paper cut
and paper cuts they don't hurt as much
as they
actually feel at the moment but
let's let's talk about some numbers that
aren't on here so if you're at home
with a pen i want you to write down that
in fy
19 the department was authorized
2 951 people
as of 11 march of this year
they had on staff
[Music]
so that's really simple math they were
authorized
300 more people than they've been able
to hire
so we we can start to see immediately
that the reality of workforce shortages
around the state and combined with the
pandemic of course and the governor's
hiring freeze
has made it so that the department
is understaffed to the tune of about 300
people
based on the fy 19
levels so so
the governor had proposed raising that
to 3226
and it just seemed to me unrealistic
because we still have a workforce
shortage
so we reduced the maximum
to 3 000. so that's 350 people
that the department can still hire on a
priority basis
that's 350 people that represents 13
growth in the number of people working
in the department i'm telling you if you
go to any company
in the united states and tell them that
you're going to let them hire 13 percent
more people
that's an absolutely unheard of level of
growth
there is no cut there is no cut this is
a 13
growth in the number of people okay
so next bullet down and i can start
moving from here because those are
really the two big things or three big
things
so we we uh we recognized that
um the department is asking for just an
absolutely enormous amount of money
to replace uh their i.t systems
and um and one of the reasons they need
so much money
is because they have a legacy system
that dates back to the early 2000s
and it's um and and it's just out of
date it's out of
maintenance and it's becoming a security
threat
so they're going to have to run some
systems in parallel for a couple years
in order to replace and modernize
so so there's money for that we
received very late in the process
a recommendation from alvarez and
do some management changes that would
result in some growth
the department had this for two weeks
longer than what they were able to
give it to us so in the last week we saw
the recommendation four of them jumped
out as making a lot of sense because the
payback period on those
was over 3x the investment
in payback in two-year period so that
was smart
we deferred other parts of that study
because
it was we just didn't have time to redo
the
their work and take a look at it so with
dcyf um the big decision
is that we uh in this budget are forcing
the closure
of the sununu center in the second year
of the budget
that's going to free up over 12 million
dollars a year
we asked the department to provide us
with some recommendations on how we
could
cut the expenses this
facility was initially uh built for 144
people
and we have a census averaging between
10 and 16
with a recidivism rate of 60 percent
and so so this is expensive and not
effective
so we need to change what we're doing
and
um and so one thing we did was and we
included an hb2
one of the house bills that came out of
children and family law i think either
unanimously or nearly unanimously
that would change the census even lower
to perhaps half
as many kids and when asked the
department
did not provide what their new
expense rates would be on a much lower
census
and so um so we're just we're just going
to have to try to force their hands
to shut sununu uh in the second year
now this was a moment of high
bipartisanship in the committee
it was really kind of the highlight i
think of our getting along and
trying to do what's right for the
community so
so the division of economic and housing
stability there
um there's some federal money
called temporary assistance to needy
families
and so we have some parents trying to go
back to work
and there's a wait list for people who
have employer-based
problems with getting uh daycare
so so this would authorize uh those
waitlists to be reduced
by using the federal tanf money
and i think that's good to get people
back to work
so the next one down on medicaid
business and policy
we fully recommen fully
funded the governor's recommendations on
the amount of money that we spend on
managed care and fee for service and
children's health insurance plans
so back to the personnel item for a
moment
if you hear somebody saying that there's
not enough people at dhhs just remember
that
almost all the direct care gets
contracted out
the there's an enormous workforce that
you don't see
it's those people providing care
through contracts and and we are not
cutting that at all
we're funding that at a very high level
um
let's see what else jumps out i'm going
to go down to elderly and adult services
this was a major policy move for us the
governor's budget came across
it showed that the amount of money that
the counties would have to
pay for the nursing homes was going to
increase
their spending year to year by about 18
percent
and when we asked rockingham county and
hillsborough county to tell us
the impact of that rockingham county
said that without a doubt
that would raise the force them to raise
the proper
the county share of their property taxes
to seven percent
or up seven percent so in order to
avoid a property tax increase we
uh ended up funding this aggressively
to where there's only a two percent uh
growth rate instead of the historic
three percent
that had been negotiated in other
budgets so this is one of those hidden
property tax cuts
that the legislature should claim credit
for but
it's probably going to get lost in the
noise just know that
you're helping your taxpayers right
there
because it's fully funding the
developmental services it's fully
funding
the acquired brain disorder services all
of these are coming across
at the governor's recommended levels so
so no cuts it it funds the children
in home support services that the
governor's recommended level two
so there's no cuts um then when we get
to the public health
the the big issue here uh really came
through
in house bill 2 where
for years there's been a week
effort to make sure that our family
planning money
goes to council couples
on family planning and and that there's
there's meant to be uh a prohibition
of using state family planning money for
um any abortion services
so while that provision has been in
place
um uh the
uh the pro-life community has pointed
out
that money is fungible and it once you
start paying these
centers the money is going to help on
the abortion side of the clinic
as well and this has been denied
every time the argument comes up and
there's a claim that
abortion doesn't receive a dime from the
family planning money
well so what an amendment does uh is
says that okay fine
we believe you let's just say that every
family planning program must have a
physical and financial separation from
the abortion services
that way we know that you're right and
what we've heard instead is that it's
absolutely impossible
we're gonna we're gonna hurt poor and
underprivileged women because
uh we're gonna uh separate the family
planning
from the abortion center and it just
can't be done well
so which is it we've heard two stories
with equal passion
so which is it and i
so i'm gonna i'm gonna skip on from
there there's more i could say
but because we're expecting
that there may be a change in who's
providing family planning services
we've put fifty thousand dollars in
there to pay up to ten thousand dollar
bonuses for new awardees
so uh so every every clinic
that's new and get it to the family
planning contract
is eligible for up to ten thousand
dollars that'll help them with one-time
expenses
or um it just may be a bonus incentive
to compete
now we've grown the family planning
money this is another thing you're going
to hear that we're cutting all these
services
no in fy 19
we spent 596 000
this year we're following the governor's
recommended budget of 812
000. that's a ten percent per year
growth rate
so we are fully funding we are
aggressively funding we are
happily funding family planning programs
we love our families we love our
children and we want to help these young
families uh bring their families into
existence
and to and to raise them well so that's
how we
we've invested in this budget um
on the state mental health system
we supported the recommendation
to have some work for workforce
enhancements
to re to recruit and retain
more workers because they have such a
high vacancy rate there
we've also removed from hb2
a paragraph that basically would have
authorized
a new 60 bed forensic mental health
hospital to be built on the grounds of
the concord hospital
and this hadn't gone to public works it
hadn't gone to
health and human services as a policy
issue so since it was such a big deal
and because it raised
the bed count from 25 to 60 with no
explanation
and it included some bonding in there
that really is
beyond the scope of uh what we should be
doing with
operating money we we pulled that out
and we're going to on the 12th have a
integrated meeting where hhs and public
works is going to come and listen and
we're going to spend the morning
you know trying to really understand
what's been going on and the extent to
which it's been coordinated with the
concord
community
and in order to take care of our vets
we fully funded their
census expected residents and and then
that concludes it i guess
i in conclusion this is a realistic
budget
it's got real growth in it it's got real
priorities in it
and it really respects the fact that we
have a great management team at dhhs
that knows how to establish priorities
and knows how to lead
because there's more than enough
resources for them to get the job done
thank you chairman edwards and now we're
going to move on to the surplus
statement this is a little bit technical
and complicated
so we're going to call on the genius of
the legislative budget assistant
mike kane to explain page 19 and
subsequent
mr kane thank you representative uh for
the record my name is michael kane i'm
the legislative budget assistant
um i'll just go through very quickly uh
the purpose of a
surplus statement for the general and
education trust fund as well as the
highway and fish and game fund
is to illustrate that the legislatures
be at the house or the senate's budget
is balanced uh pursuant to rsa 98
b so right here in front of you
it's a combined general education trust
fund in 21
uh the governor in house finance began
with a negative balance forward from 20
of about 54.4 million dollars
uh a majority of that due to the revenue
loss
in fy 20 uh due to the pandemic so a
negative balance did carry forward into
21.
estimated revenues based on the latest
estimates provided by house ways and
means
in march i believe was march 18th
as well as a revenue adjustment which is
a restricted
revenue from the education trust fund to
fund the one-time
fiscal capacity disparity and free and
reduced lunch bump
that was provided for the last budget so
total revenue is about 2.78
billion dollars in the house finance
estimates
working with ways and means as far as
budget appropriations
in total uh approximately two billion
seven hundred twenty one
thousand seven hundred twenty seven
dollars in appropriations that includes
about
2 billion 796 million in section 1 which
is the large
portion or your state totals in house
bill 1 as well as appropriation
adjustments which are in the subsequent
schedule two
again largest one being the offset of
the revenue of the 62.5 above
uh for the one-time education aid from
the last biennium
that leads the current year balance of
about 66.47
million dollars across both the general
and education trust fund
a cumulative ending balance of about
12.066
million however the that is
split between the education trust fund
which has a positive 19
million 896 million dollar balance it is
non-lapsing
but 21 based on the revenues just based
on today
uh it's assumed that there will be a
general fund shortfall of about 7.8
million dollars if revenues do come in
under plan there's an automatic
or two two triggers that need to be met
in statute
or two instances one being an operating
budget deficit the second being that
revenues
for the current biannual below the
planned revenues
and if that were to record that would
require a draw on the rainy day fund
of about 7.8 million dollars again a
little too early
to predict just based on the estimates
we have today
and the appropriations as well as the
estimated lapse
updated we do believe sitting here today
there could be a drop of about 7.8
million but obviously the senate
ways and means committee and the house
wage means committee will continue to
look at the performance of general
education trust fund revenue in march
and april
as they develop their estimates for the
next biennium
the balance forward into 22 that's all
the education trust fund as it is
non-lapsing
of about 19.9 million rounded
carried forward estimated revenues
including revenue adjustments from the
tax changes
proposed in the bill which were briefly
uh discussed
in the previous by the previous
presenters results in total revenues
about 2.749 billion dollars
in 22 appropriations from both sources
including a lapse estimate of about 71
million dollars based on the actions
taken by the divisions
our appropriation is about 2.7 billion
dollars for current year balance of 47.2
billion
of that 60 and if you add the balance
forward
the 22 current cumulative ending balance
is 67.1 million
being the middle of the biennium any
balance at the close of fiscal year 22
will carry forward into the following
year so you can see
in the final column uh the beginning
balance in 23 of about 67.1 million
dollars
estimated revenues again based on the
house ways and means estimates
provided for in march is about 2.8
billion dollars
revenue adjustments a reduction of those
revenues of about 118
million dollars across both funds the
largest being the reduction
of 100 million dollars in the statewide
property tax so total revenues in 23
estimated about 2.682 billion dollars
uh budget appropriations about 2.830
uh billion dollars in house bill one and
then positive adjustments of about 17.9
million dollars
in that offsets appropriations that
includes the back of the budget
uh adjustments that representative
edwards had just discussed
including an estimated lapse in the
second year of the biennium of about
98.2 million dollars
brings the total appropriations for that
fiscal year to about 2.71415 billion
dollars
our current year balance is a negative
32.2 largely due to the
one-time reduction of the statewide
property tax of 100 million dollars
and then the cumulative ending balance
is 34.934
that 34.934 is all general fund balance
at the end of the biennium any excess
general funds will be transferred to the
rainy day fund so that would result
right as we sit here today uh based on
this proposal
a transfer to the rainy day fund of
about 34.9 million
uh bringing the balance up to 142.6
million dollars for the biennium and if
we could scroll down to the next
a couple pages i'll just show you really
quick on the general
that was the total combined general
education trust fund if you want to see
the individual
general fund versus the education trust
fund here's the general fund if you look
in the final column you can see that uh
cumulative ending balance of about 34.9
million dollars which is then
transferred to the
rainy day fund and if you could scroll
down please
thank you these are the revenue
estimates uh for the general funds
specifically uh based on those estimates
provided by
house waste means these are your base
estimates and then if we could scroll
through the next couple of pages um
you can keep going there are two
sections on schedule two one are revenue
adjustments as well as appropriation
adjustments so it goes into detail
everything that was presented to you
in the previous 45 minutes has been
outlined and accounted for
so that all the adjustments are included
and if we move forward to schedule three
this is the education trust fund
and if we look into 23 there is a
current year balance in negative 92.38
and again the reason for that is the
one-time reduction in the statewide
education property tax
which is offset by a general fund
appropriation and transfer of about 65.4
million dollars which brings the balance
of the education trust fund to zero
at the end of 23. and if we went through
the next couple
of schedules we have the education trust
fund portion of revenue estimates
uh governor versus house finance and if
we scroll to the next schedule
four this is similar to your schedule
two for the general fund or all the
adjustments
um for the revenues and appropriations
uh that are listed
i mean you can see the hundred million
dollars on row 11 kind of jumps out at
you
and if we could go forward uh to the
next
item this is the highway fund
it's on a smaller scale than the
previous
um but this is a
an illustration of the highway fund to
show that it is
balanced based on the house finance
proposal
you can see on row 34 27 about 27 000
is the so-called the gap uh basis and
cash on hand is on road 29 that's about
22.5 in cash on hand
uh 32 of your gap adjustments for the
highway fund which the comptroller
and the agencies work on and those are
due to timing or any other revenues
on how they fall within the fiscal year
but about
row 34 you usually want to see a
positive or a zero
on that line after you account for gap
adjustments and if we move forward to
the fishing game
surplus statement again this is a
document showing that the house finance
plan and the fish and game fund
uh is also balanced with an ending
balance of about
6.027 million dollars
at the end of 23 for the fish and game
fund
is this just a state aid schedule
something we'll we'll be creating
um we'll be creating this
throughout the session to show what the
actual state aid for 2821 as well as the
governor recommended
house finance senate as well as the
final pass on state aid
on a summary level and that's
all i have for my presentation i know
that kevin
ripple is man and mickey are managing um
the zoom called right now representative
weiler and
if the attendees the house members have
a question
they would like to ask if they could
raise their hand and we could pull them
over
as a panelist and so that the members of
the committee can answer their questions
i can answer any technical question
relative to the surplus statement i
think the members of the chairs as you
have just seen will be able to answer a
lot of the other
questions you have uh specific to the
budget and so
i'll end my presentation and turn it
over to uh represent wilder
and kevin's going to notify you of who
thank you mr kane and we're grateful for
your staff members that
stood by us in every division and every
change and kept track of all these
things so that
we could finally total it all up and
know what we did
so we're open now for any questions from
the house members raise your hand and
mr cain will recognize you and bring you
in
it looks like the first person who had
their hand up was representative stacey
marie lawton and she's a panelist and
should be able to speak now
thank you my question is um
is there anything in the budget for peer
i believe there is uh representative
edwards peer support group
is that was that in hhs yep
are are you saying peer p-e-e-r
yeah it would be in with the department
of health and human services
you know honestly in a
5.9 billion dollar budget i i don't
recall that line item
so um i i i take an assist from mr
ripple if he can tell me that we had a
there is a peer support line item i off
the top of my head i don't recall
what did that um
but i can i can get that information and
get back to you representative yeah
so if you'll send me an email uh i'll
i'll get a
the next question i believe the next
person with their hand up was
representative michael cahill
uh yes thank you my question is for
representative ober
about the liquor enforcement slash
education
uh who will be doing the inspection of
our thousands of uh
alcohol serving uh institutions and the
uh
convenience stores selling cigarettes
as i said represent peter leishman
worked on this extensively there is
still a great deal of staff in there
to do inspections licensing
and education so we did not
defund the entire group we remove the
ones who are acting as police officers
left the licensors
i know that the department had been
looking for more people to do
inspections
was that addressed the department did
not ask for more staffing
when we found representative cahill
there was a 300 page
audit that we all read on this specific
division
and they were with even that 21 people
they were doing less than half of the
inspections they should have been doing
so they were doing other activities
rather than
what we assumed was the purpose of the
inspection division
so that's why we made the change thank
you
and the next question and i apologize in
advance if i butcher anybody's name here
it's
i think it's bound to happen is
representative jackie
grot
thank you that was correct um
this is a question regarding uh division
three
i believe um the um modernizing
of the i.t struck infrastructure within
the department
um how much can you speak up please
representative
yes is this better not much
no i'll i'll speak louder
can you please tell me how much money
how much money is being provided for the
funding to upgrade
the um i.t infrastructure
mentioned i believe it was for division
three in
the department of health and human
services how much how much funding is
the the totality of the funding for
it services and support and division
three
is spread out amongst many different
lines
the the the biggest chunk uh was related
to the medicaid
uh management information system
replacement
and we moved that into hb2
and when we moved that uh i believe it
was on the order
of 35 million over the two years
and and mr ripple feel free to correct
me if i'm wrong it could have been as
high as 43 million
but it was it was a lot of money and
then uh
they the it
budget is bigger than that because they
have
personnel lines uh for it
and they have also uh regular
operating costs associated with with
running and licensing their it
services so so all together
if all the different line items were
aggregated
and i never saw it all aggregated in one
place
if if we were spending 60 to 65 million
over the two years just for dhhsit
i would say that would be kind of on the
low range
and it could it could be as high as 75
million when
all combined does that help
yes i was interested in the medicare
medicaid
part of it so you answered my question i
have another quick question
it's up to the chairman and i it really
is hard to hear you by the way
okay is this better the uh
the i.t is is present in every
department across
state government and the employees
are assigned to i.t although they might
be permanently in all the different
departments
so that it can have a universal and
common uh procedures that they all
follow
there's also help desks and things like
that that some of the smaller agencies
that don't have
someone internally can call a help desk
and so all those funds are transferred
in and around government
and so it's difficult to track them
by that one department i'm sure we have
the total somewhere but it's going to
take a little homework to
to add it all up and if you uh
send a query to lba they can probably
get that for you
thank you thank you if i may mr chair
if i could receive all of the questions
and then i'll coordinate them with
lba so it's it's to uh
jess edwards thank you for your email
i just want to make sure all the
representatives get their full questions
answered
thank you are you hearing me yes
thank you very much i am interested in a
bill
and i wish i could remember the name
that was passed last year
in the last session it was some of the
lead
bill and a rather massive health care
bill that we passed
the opening bill was i believe it was 13
59 or 69
something like that which is a bill i
sponsored and it was about medicaid in
and out this would affect division three
and it was to correct the 30 year old
problem that existed in
the early 90s this program
under medicaid was brought into play for
individuals whose income was well above
the income that qualified them for
medicaid
but they had such extensive medical
problems
that uh for example somebody on
that earned ten thousand dollars a year
and had
uh dialysis on a regular basis their
costs
out-of-pocket costs without any
insurance
would have brought their income way down
below
and what this bill allowed them to do
is if the spend down was reached so the
spend down brought them down
to the federal poverty level of at that
time it was
591 dollars a month
they they would then begin receiving
medicaid for the balance of the month to
pay the additional costs
this was supposed to be brought into
effect
it was that poverty level that was
brought down to
was 591 certainly the cost of living has
increased significantly
since the early 1990s 30 years ago
and the intent of this bill was to bring
it up to the current level
so that individuals with these extensive
medical expenses
once they reach the federal poverty
level now the balance
of the expenses they ran that month
would be covered by medicaid
and up until then they'd have to spend
their own funds to leak
but they wouldn't have to go beyond
which brought them down to the level
that qualified them
for quality this is a long explanation
does that make sense does anybody
remember this bill
and why was this not why were no funds
included in this particular bill in
order to
bring this into being was it even
considered
so representative snow it's so good to
hear your voice i hope you're doing well
sir
i'm doing very well and thank you i i
was on ways and means last term and
and not paying attention to all the hhs
bills um we missed you too but if it
passed
last term then i'm confident
that the department has factored in
whatever
eligibility requirements that law lays
out
in in that the governor's process
of coming up with a proposed budget
made sure that there were funds adequate
to cover that new
eligibility category and in general
in all direct health care we accepted
the governor's budget
so so without being able to be specific
uh i
i think we're probably okay and if if
you'll send me an email sir
i i will uh work to to find out
um what i need to about the eligibility
and get your goods i will
just for further information when i did
check with the
department uh and the medic the
personnel in the medicaid
they did say that they understood it
they had a plan in place
but they did say that as far as they
knew there was nothing included in the
budget
to cover whatever additional costs it
would be which is
i don't remember the exact amount of
what it was but it's it's not
significant but
their understanding was there was no
money included in the budget to cover
the
additional costs for this to bring these
people back from
a 30 year old threshold to qualify for
care but
i will be glad to send you a memo with
that kind of information
in if you could do anything to expedite
moving that along it would be a big help
it's it's very important for people who
have these chronic medical conditions
it's also
a help for people with conditions like
neurological conditions mental health
conditions
where they have ongoing expenses that
are pretty extraordinary and they don't
mr ripple do you know any of the history
i believe uh the representative snow is
correct and that it's not funded in the
budget
if that's the case it also funded in the
governor's recommended budget
but i would have to go back and check
with the department on the history of it
thank you very much i appreciate it
thank you
next next is representative timothy
horrigan
well can you hear me um i can i could
uh my own question is uh the governor's
budget included a significant increase
in the legislative branch's budget which
i think is
a good idea given um given i think we've
been understaffed despite the great work
you do mr ripple and all the legislative
staffers i think we don't have enough
staff for enough resources but i'm kind
of
surprised that he would be increasing
the resources so is that was he
is that an operational increase or is
that just to pay for
like the things like building new
entrants the lob and then
also i haven't haven't heard anything
about issues since
uh what's what's happening to our budget
representative oregon the legislative
budget by state law
is handled by the facilities committee
and not the finance committee
all right and do you have any
input on what they're planning to do
here
i do not sit on the facilities committee
sir i do not know
okay i mean i i do not either i mean i
try as best i can to keep track of what
they're doing but um they you know they
don't publish
a lot of information about what they're
doing most of the time so
um so you so you there's no comment on
what that was all about or what are
whether uh will we be investing more
your knowledge and um you know upgrading
our
we had to do like i think about 13 years
worth of change in a few months this
year which cost a lot of money but
um you're not coming through very
clearly here
okay i'm sorry i'm trying to speak up
i've been able to hear the people who
are coming in remotely
with no problem and i've been able to
hear you but you're sitting in the halls
so
um so okay so i guess that's about the
answer we're going to get that
nobody knows and it's up to the joint
facilities committee
i think if i were you i would email the
facilities committee chairman i'm sure
that's on the house website
and with the client i mean they don't
they don't really post much information
about what transpires that they're
meeting so unless they're actually at
the meeting um it's kind of hard to
follow what they're doing
but uh that's uh okay well i'm uh
thanks for the information then so i
wish okay thanks
there's no more hands up that's correct
i thank you all for your attention uh
hope you will support this budget we've
worked hard with it without the able
assistance of the legislative budget
assistant
we think it's balanced we think it'll
fill the needs of the people of our
state
and we'll be talking about it more on
wednesday i thank you all for your
attention